you've opened up a shoe factory and
you're trying to figure out how many
thousands of pairs to shoot of shoes to
produce in order to optimize your profit
and so let's let x equal the thousands
of
pairs produced thousands
of pairs
pairs produced
now let's think about how much money
you're going to make per pair actually
let me say how much revenue which is how
much do you actually get to sell those
shoes for so let's write a function
right here revenue as a function of x
well you have a whole seller who's
willing to pay you ten dollars per pair
for as many pairs as you're willing to
give him so your revenue as a function
of x is going to be 10
times x and since x is in thousands of
pairs produced if x is one that means
one thousand pairs produced times ten
which means ten thousand dollars but
this will just give you ten so this
right over here is in thousands of
dollars
thousands
of thousands of dollars so if x is one
that means one thousand pairs produced
ten times one says r is equal to ten but
that really means ten thousands of
dollars ten thousand dollars
now it would be a nice business if all
you had was revenue and no costs but you
do have costs you have materials you
have to build your factory you have to
pay your employees you have to pay the
electricity bill and so you hire a bunch
of consultants to come up with what your
cost is as a function of x
what your cost is as a function of x and
they come up with a function they say it
is the number of the thousands of pairs
you produce cubed minus six times the
thousands of pairs you produce squared
plus 15 times the thousands of pairs
that you produce and once again this is
going to be this is also going to be in
thousands of dollars
now given this this these functions of x
for revenue and cost what is going to be
your your what is what is profit as a
function of x going to be
well your profit
your profit as a function of x is just
going to be equal to your revenue as a
function of x
minus your cost as a function of x
minus your cost as a function of x if
you produce a certain amount and let's
say you bring in i don't know ten
thousand dollars of revenue and it costs
you five thousand dollars to produce
those shoes you'll have five thousand
dollars in profit those numbers aren't
the ones that would actually you would
get from this right here i'm just giving
you an example
so this is what you want to optimize you
want to optimize
p as a function
optimize p as a function of x so what is
it i've just said it here in abstract
terms but we know what r of x is and
what's c of x this is 10x
this is 10 x
minus all of this business so
minus x to the third
plus 6x squared minus 15x i just
subtracted x squared you subtract a 6x
squared becomes positive you subtract a
15x it becomes negative 15x and then we
can simplify this as let's see we have
negative x to the third
plus 6 x squared minus 15x plus 10x so
that is
minus 5x
now if we want to optimize this profit
function analytically the easiest way is
to think about what are the critical
points of this profit function and are
any of those critical points minimum
points or maximum points and if one of
them is a maximum point then we can say
well let's produce that many that is
going to be we will have optimized or
we'll figure out the quantity we need to
produce in order to optimize our profit
so to figure out critical points we
essentially have to find the derivative
of our function and figure out when does
that derivative equal 0 or when is that
derivative undefined that's the
definition of critical points so pre p
prime of x is going to be equal to
negative 3 x squared plus 12 x
minus 5. and so this thing is going to
be defined for all x so the only
critical points we're going to have is
when this the first derivative right
over here is equal to 0.
so negative 3x squared plus 12x minus 5
needs to be equal to 0 in order for x to
be a critical point so now we just have
to solve for x and so we just are
essentially solving a quadratic equation
and just so that i don't have as many
negatives let's multiply both sides by
negative 1. i just like to have a clean
first coefficient so if we multiply both
sides by negative 1 we get 3x squared
minus 12x plus 5 is equal to 0 and now
we can use the quadratic formula to
solve for x so x is going to be equal to
negative b which is 12. plus or minus
the square root i always need to make my
radical signs wide enough the square
root of b squared which is 144
minus 4 times a which is 3
times c which is 5
times 5
all of that all of that over 2a so 2
times 3 is 6.
so x is equal to 12
plus or minus the square root of let's
see 4 times 3 is 12 times 5 is 60.
144 minus 60 is
84
all of that over 6. so x could be equal
to 12 plus the square root of 84 over 6
or x could be equal to 12 minus the
square root of 84
over 6. so let's figure out what these
two are and i'll use a calculator i'll
use i'll use the calculator for this one
so i get
i get let's see
12
plus
the square root
of 84
divided by 6 divided by 6
gives me
3.5 i'll just say 3.53
so approximately
approximately three
point actually let me go one more let me
go one more digit because i'm talking
about thousands so let me say 3.528
three point five two eight three point
five
two eight so this would literally be
three thousand five hundred and twenty
eight shoes because this is in thousands
and let's do
our pairs of shoes and then let's do the
situation where we subtract and actually
we can do sec we can look at our
previous entry and just change this to a
subtraction
change that to not a negative sign a
subtraction
there you go and we get .47
0.47 let me remember that 0.4725
approximately equal to
0.4725 have a horrible memory so let me
review that i wrote the same thing four
seven
four seven two five yep all right
now these are all we know about these or
these are both critical points these are
points at which our derivative is equal
to zero but we don't know whether their
minimum points their points at which the
function becomes takes on a minimum
value a maximum value or neither to do
that i'll use the second derivative test
to figure out if our function is concave
upwards or concave downwards or neither
at one of these points so let's look at
the second derivative
so p
prime prime of x is going to be equal to
negative 6 x
plus
negative 6x plus 12. and so if we look
if we look at let me make sure i have
enough space
so if we look at p prime prime p prime
prime of 3.528
so let's see if i can think this through
so this is between 3 and 4 so if we take
the lower value 3 times negative 6 is
negative 18 plus 12 is going to be less
than 0 and if this was 4 it it'd be even
more negative so this thing is going to
be less than zero don't even have to use
my calculator to evaluate it now what
about this thing right over here point
four seven
well .47 that's going to get us that's
roughly 0.5 so negative 6 times 0.5 is
negative 3 this is going to be nowhere
close to being negative this is
definitely going to be positive so p
prime prime of 0.4725
is greater than 0. so the fact that the
second derivative is less than zero that
means that my derivative is decreasing
my derivative my first derivative is
decreasing when x is equal to this value
which means that our our graph our
function is concave downwards here
concave
concave
downwards and concave downwards means it
looks it looks something like this and
so and you can see when it looks
something like that the slope the slope
is constantly decreasing so if you have
an interval where the slope is
decreasing and you know the point where
the slope is exactly zero which is where
x is equal to 3.528 it must be
it must be a maximum it must be a
maximum so we actually do take on a
maximum value when x is 3.528
on the other side we see that over here
we're concave upwards concave
upwards
concave upwards the graph will look
something like this over here and if the
slope is zero where the graph looks like
that we see that that is a that is a
local minimum
that is a local minimum
and so we definitely don't want to do
this we would produce four 472 and a
half units if we were if we were looking
to minimize our profit maximize our loss
so we definitely don't want to do this
but let's actually think about what our
profit is going to be if we produce 3.5
to 8 thousands of shoes or
3528 shoes well to do that we just have
to input it back into our original
profit function right over here so let's
do that so get my calculator out so
my original profit function is right
over there so i want to be able to see
that and that so i get
negative
3.528
to the third power to the third power
plus
6
times
3.528
squared
minus 5 times
3.528 gives me and we get a drum roll
now gives me a profit of gives me a
profit of 13.128
so let me write this down the profit
when i produce
twenty 3528 shoes
is approximately equal to or it is equal
to if i produce exactly that many shoes
it's equal to
three thirteen point one two eight
or actually it's approximately because
i'm still rounding thirteen 13.128
so if i produce
3528 shoes in a given period i am going
to have a profit of 13
128
remember this right over here is in
thousands this right over here is 13.128
thousands of dollars in profit which is
13 128
anyway we are now going to be rich shoe
manufacturers